if learning After Effects has kept you
from creating stunning Motion Graphics
and visual effects I've got a solution
for you called After Effects Academy Vol
1. in this five hour starter course
you'll learn which After Effects panels
to use and how to use them you'll learn
navigation tips and optimal workflow
setups you'll learn masking and matte
methods type tool techniques shape layer
design Dynamic workflows and at the end
of this course you'll even learn how to
design and animate an impressive title
sequence and as an additional bonus on
top of all this after effects training
I'm also throwing in a huge sample pack
of our film and grunge textures and the
motion science prolut package this
training contains over 20 years of After
Effects experience gained from working
on projects for top clients such as BMW
MTV Microsoft Disney and more students
who have taken this training will tell
you that the content and approach to
After Effects taught in these lessons is
unlike anything they've seen before and
no I'm not going to charge you hundreds
of dollars like this training has gone
for in the past you can join today for
just 27 so click below get signed up get
instant access to everything apply what
you learn and see immediate improvements
in your skills or your money back I'll
see you inside the course